this question in complex numbers takes
advantage of one of the strengths of
complex numbers
in that it represents a lot of ideas and
concepts
in a very succinct way because it uses
symbols
and algebra rather than having to you
know rely on words or shapes and
geometry
however that also can be a bit of a
disadvantage when you're trying to
understand what it is that the question
is asking you
it clothes all of these ideas we're
familiar with shapes
and and words and it puts it in this
very very succinct
abstract form that makes you think what
does the question even mean what is it
asking me so we have to do a fair bit of
interpretation
to expand um and translate as it were
what's happening
into geometry and shapes and then we can
sort of work with the algebra from there
so
let's dive in the complex number z
satisfies the equation modulus for z
minus 1 equals
1. we'll come back to this idea in
a minute like what exactly this means
prove that and then here's the result
that i need to end on as it were the
square of the modulus of z
equals double the real part
of z that's the way that i would read
that
then they suggest to us a couple of
steps here and here which we'll dive
into
shortly first we need to understand what
what on earth does this mean
the modulus of z minus one equals one so
the complex number z uh if i just say z
is somewhere on the complex plane it
could be anywhere
but when we say oh the complex number z
satisfies
this equation that means there are
particular values of z for which this
works
so for example if i said to you there's
a pair of numbers
x and y that satisfy the equation y
equals
x squared you sort of because we've
dealt with this idea for a long time
you're sort of involuntarily i hope
picturing a shape right a parabola
now what we mean by this parabola its
connection to the equation is
if you pick any spot on this parabola
for instance
one of the spots might be you know three
comma nine
um if you substitute x equals three and
y equals nine into this equation
it works but if i put a point like say
uh
you know three comma 0. if you put that
into the equation it doesn't work right
so this x and this y
this one this pair doesn't satisfy this
equation but this one does
so there are some values of z and they
live on the complex plane
that satisfy this equation and for those
particular
complex numbers i want to prove that
this is true that if i take
the modulus to any of those particular
complex numbers and then square it
what i end up with is double the real
part of that particular complex number
so how do i do that well they first say
let z equals
x plus iy seems a bit uh vague and
unhelpful
and then they say square that equation
and use this particular
result so i need to think about this for
a second um you know they give us this
result here
but i don't even really know how that's
going to come into play and i don't know
how it's going to be useful
so the first thing that i'm going to do
is i'm actually going to do this
question
backwards um if you already know uh you
know what this means and where it comes
from then that's great you can just dive
straight in
but for someone meeting this question
for the first time and maybe um being a
little bit hazy about what that means
i want to understand what that thing
means because otherwise i won't be able
to use it so i think that will help me
going forward
so let's unpack this in reverse order
what i'm going to say is
what does this thing mean the absolute
value or the modulus of z
squared equals z times z
bar well i think that the best way to
understand this again as with the whole
question is actually backwards right
so rather than start here i'm actually
going to start on the right hand side
because i know exactly what these two
things mean
this is the modulus for z and this is
the conjugate sorry
start again this is the complex number z
and this is the conjugate
of that complex number z so what happens
when you multiply
uh a number by its conjugate well when i
think about
what this looks like on the complex
plane i think the easiest way to
illustrate this is with what we've
learned from
uh polar form right so if i were to say
okay i have some complex number z up
here
where would its conjugate belong well
it's going to be on the opposite side of
the real number line
down here right we said it's kind of
this reflection
vertically across uh y equals zero the
real number line right
now as a consequence of that being a
reflection i can say that the
arguments here have a particular
relationship with each other um they're
going to be theta
and negative theta remembering that i'm
thinking about the principle argument
here
i'm not talking about the magnitude i'm
also including its direction right
um and then of course you can also see
that because it's the same number
reflected down they're going to have the
same modulus right
that r is going to be the same as that r
so what happens when i multiply
these two i'll stay on orange when i
when i multiply these two numbers
together
z multiplied by its conjugate well in
polar form
i would say that the first number is r
cos theta plus i
sine theta and then i'm multiplying that
by
its conjugate which has the same modulus
so that's still
r but then it's got the opposite
argument so it's going to be cos of
negative theta plus i sine of
negative theta now what do i do when i'm
multiplying two complex numbers
especially when they're in polar form
answer i multiply the moduli and i add
the arguments so this is a really nice
neat way to avoid all of the trig
expansions
so here are the right here
and here the moduli they're both r so i
just get r
squared hanging out the front and then
because my
arguments are theta and negative theta
when i add them
they just cancel out it's going to be
theta plus negative theta
which is 0 in both cases so therefore i
get cos
of 0 plus i sine
of 0 that's what i get from my theta
plus negative theta
now these are again nice neat exact
values
hopefully you remember that sine theta
is 0
so sine 0 is 0 and cos 0 is 1
right so therefore what i get here is 1
plus how many lots of i
zero lots of i so what i'm getting here
is
r squared but r by definition is the
modulus of z so i could also write that
as the absolute value modulus of z
like so z and z bar
but also noting that you can see where
they're going here in the question
if i take the rectangular form of a
complex number if i
now switch from rs and thetas into x's
and y's
if i have oopsy daisy
if i have a right angle triangle which
has
r in it then my horizontal part is x my
vertic my vertical part is y
and because it's in a right angled
triangle i'm getting pythagorases here
right pythagoras theorem here so this is
r squared equals
x squared plus y squared so what i've
got here
is that maybe a better way to write it
is this identity or this
equation they gave me here is true and
they're both equal to x squared
plus y squared so what i'm going to do
is now i know what that result means i'm
going to tuck it in the back
away in the back of my mind and then i'm
going to have a think about well
what is this question asking me to do in
this particular context
so let's have a go now at part a
it says let z equal x
plus i y you're like well what does that
do
okay where am i going to put this well
in the question right from the outset
they said that's not just any number
z is this particular set of numbers that
satisfies this equation right so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to take
that x plus iy
and i'm going to substitute it into here
so i can say
if which it is if the absolute value of
z
minus 1 actually was it minus 1 or is it
plus 1 oopsie
it's minus 1 there we go i'm not going
crazy equals 1
then i can just put in x plus
i y minus 1 equals 1. all right
now what is the point of doing this well
here some of the geometry that's hiding
underneath the abstract symbols will
really help
okay in past questions we've seen we can
interpret this as meaning
the distance between z my complex number
and one right in the same way that we
might say
the absolute value of 7 take away 4
what that really means is the distance
between 7 and 4
which is 3 right so i can think of this
as the distance between two complex
numbers but what this helps me to do and
i'm going to show you the algebra in a
second
is recognize that i can also think of
this left-hand side not as the distance
between
z and 1 i can also think of it as the
distance between z minus 1
which is a separate complex number and
the origin now what that would
correspond
to in our absolute absolute value terms
on the real number line
is to say well i can just evaluate 7
minus 4 is the absolute value of
negative 3.
right so this is the distance from
negative 3
to the origin which itself is also 3.
so what would this look like on the
complex plane let's just draw a quick
sketch for ourselves i'll use purple
because i
um i think i haven't used it in this
question yeah let's do it
so on the complex plane what would this
mean well
if the absolute value of um of z
is um somewhere right i'm going to put z
somewhere on
to like say
here we'll do right let's put z there
i'm comparing that
to the other complex number one and what
i'm suggesting is
that let's use this color here what i'm
suggesting is this distance here
is the absolute value of z minus one
that modulus right that's the absolute
value of z minus 1 the distance between
z
and 1 on the complex plane but now i can
say
well i can think of z minus 1 as its own
complex number just like
negative 3 is its own place on the real
number line
if this is z where is z minus one
well because this is a shift and it's a
shift in the real direction because
that's a real number right there minus
one i can say well
i am shifted one unit to the
left right so i can say oh i'm going to
go
this way like so
and i'm going to say this guy here this
is
z minus 1. okay now what is the distance
from that
to the origin well it's going to be this
distance over here
isn't it right and you can see these are
exactly equal in fact i should do it in
that same color that i had
over here
those distances are clearly equivalent
to each other because i have this
parallel
parallelogram going on here and so being
that these are equal
that's why this is also the absolute
value of z
minus one they're both the same distance
so maybe i'll just
indicate that with a couple of these
lines here now
how do i interpret that over here with
my rectangular form that they've asked
me to use
well i would say here to work out the
modulus to
this whole thing as a complex number
what i should do is i should write this
with the real part and the imaginary
part
together separate at the moment i've got
a real bit here and i've got another
real bit here right so let's let's
collect them together
what i would say is this is the absolute
value of x
minus 1 is that component there
and that's the real bit and then i have
i y
over on this side that's just the
imaginary part that i've written over
here
that's all apparently equal to 1.
okay now how is this useful to me right
well
they said let z equal this and then
square the equation
well why do i need to square this well
the reason why squaring
is useful is because by definition
the modulus to this point is
from pythagoras like we saw before the
square root of a squared plus b squared
where this is my a and this is my b so
here comes a squared and here comes
b squared that's the definition of how i
evaluate the modulus using pythagoras
now you can see why in this question
they said square that equation
and then use this other result which i
proved up above so let's go ahead and
square this
i get x minus 1 all squared plus y
squared
equals 1. and the instinct here is to do
a bit of expanding because that'll let
me simplify a little bit right
on the left hand side i get x squared
minus 2x plus 1.
i've also got that y squared there
hanging out and then 1 and the most
obvious thing to do in this case is to
subtract 1 from both sides because that
will cancel right so this will give me x
squared minus 2x
plus y squared equals 1. now
at this point you should pause because
sorry that's not equal to 1 that's equal
to 0.
at this point you should pause because
you've sort of done all the obvious
simplification so where do i go next
well that depends on what you were
supposed to do in the first place
let's go back to the original question
it said
prove that the modulus of z or squared
equals two times the real part of z
what does that mean well uh let's let's
take this one piece at a time right the
at the modulus of z all squared
is going to be equal to z times z pi and
that's the thing that i did
here you see here i have the modulus of
z all squared
equals the product z times z bar
which itself is equal to x squared plus
y squared now that's familiar to me
because
i've got an x squared and a y squared
right here
x squared and y squared so that's good
what's the other thing i need to do
well i need to prove that that is equal
to double
the real part of z what is the real part
of z well because i've written this in
rectangular form
the real part of z is just x isn't it
so therefore you can see double the real
part of z is just going to be double
uh whoopsie daisy it's just going to be
double x which
is also right here so all i need to do
from this point
is to say x squared plus y squared leave
that on the left hand side
that is if you add 2x to both sides 2x
but the absolute value sorry the
x plus y squared that i see on the x
squared plus y squared i can see on the
left hand side
is what i worked out before the modulus
of z
or squared and on the right hand i've
got double x which is
double the real part of z and that is
the result that i was asked
to prove so what can we learn from this
well
a lot of the results that you can see
here i had to rely on some geometry it
was kind of hidden
from view because of all these symbols
right so what i would always suggest is
when when you get given things things
like this you should interpret them
visually
and be able to say oh okay what does r
squared mean it lives in a right angle
triangle and so that's where you can get
things like this
which end up being algebraically useful
to you
and that's how you can also prove the
result that you need the other thing
that's important is when they ask you to
prove some algebraic result
you should always think about what does
that mean in terms that i'm more
familiar with so that's why
we use this result here and i proved it
right at the start so that i would know
where i was going to and then this guy
here well i'm going to use this result
in terms of how they asked us to phrase
z in in rectangular form
rather than using two times the real
part of z
it's much easier to conceptualize that
as 2x because i can spot that in the
algebra
so i hope that's helpful